AMAZING SPECIAOPERIONS
WAIOR FOUNDATION ANDT'S ALL
A MADE,.
HAPPY TUESDAY.
AT A MARVELO TIME TO BE
IVE.
IF U AREN'T WORKING FOCNN
PLUS
SIX BUR
U SHOULD CONSIR YOURSELF LUCKY U
NOT JU BECAUSE YOU'R WAHING
FORMER CAIN KLEINNDERAR
MODEL THAT PPENS TO BE
THINKING OF LE-NIGHT
THOU YOU SHOULD BE.
GRITUD MATTERS.WHEN THIS SO SHE.
I STL THW IT IN HER FE.
DO YOU SHOW ENGH GRATITE FOR
ALL TH GAT THINGS IN YOUR LIFE
ARE YOUGREFUL FOR YOUR FAMILY
?
YO FRIENDS, YOURROCTOGIST
WITH REALLY SLEND NGER
AND AT ABOUT ME?ARE YOU ANKFUL ?
WHY NOT SHOW IT.
WHY NOT GEA TATT OF MY NAME
ON YOUR FAC
WH IS STOPPING Y?
YOU'REPCOMING JOB TERVIEW.
GNITY?
THAT'S NOT STOING LEE'S
HEANDEPARADE HE VOWTO GET
TATTOOED O HIS FACE.ME
SENTENCE.HE MIGHT BE LYING, AFT
IS AMURDERER, BUT IT'S GREA NOW
LIBERA POLICIES BTHE TTOO
OWNER.
HE SAIDHE PADED ILTY TO
MURDER AS WL ASERSONAL E
OF A FIREARMOR THE KILLING OF
LIVERY PERSON BACK  2019.
IT RAISED THE QUEION WHAT
OTHER THAN RSONAL USE WILL USE
YO ARTHE SHOOTER.
ALSO HE KILL A POT DELIRY
RSON.
WHY NOT JUS KILL SAN CLAUS.
MY RIGHT, C?
>> BECAUSE I DO DRUGS
>> E DIO OF THE JAILHOUSE
PHE CA OBINED BY FOX WS
S E MURDERER GUSNG ABOUT
THE GREAT THINGS TT HE DID FOR
HIM.
>> I GOT CUT FM THE 14TH.
APPEAR TO.OING TO DR MY GANG EN
>>E IS MAKING HIORIC CHANGES
FOR ALLOF U, NOT JUST
MURDERERS, ANDTHEN WE BECOME
HISTY TO
AN IF HE KILLS , ON HAS TO DO I.
YOU'RE LASTORDSOULD BE WHY WOUL.
OF COURSE NOTHING SA TOUGH ON
CRIME BY GETTING RGING
ENDORSENT FROM A CONCTED
MUERER, ATLET SOMEONE IS FINALL.
T MABE GETTING TATTOOS T
CELEBRATE SKATINGREE IS MORE
COMMON THAN U THINK.
THAT STORY ABT THAT TATTOOGUY
CELEBRATE BEATG THSYSTEM.
THAT'S WHENI BEAT THAT
SHOPLIFTING CHGE.
>> KATZ,HAT IS INSANE.
IT'S KE YOU'RE IN AIKER GANG
.
IS WHEN I DIDN'T GET IN TROUBLE.
THEOLORS ARE SO VID.
IT RLLY ACCENTUATES R IT
ONE.HIS  PROBABLY MY FAVORITE
I DI'T EN GET IN TROUBLEOR
>> MY GOD COMING YOU'RE SO
MUSCULAR, D HARRY.
THAIS IN ALZHEIME.SO HARRY.
ENTUALLY THEYGAIN BANGOR
FACED LIFE SENNCEWITHOUT THE
POSSIBILIT OF ROLE FACING
WHAT IS I'M T TALKING ABOUT
COLLAGEN INJECTIONS EIGHFOR
AMPLE BEING I AANG SHLD
CONTAINING CRIMILS  SEEN  .
OPPRESVE, ESPECIALLY IN NEVA
ININGES ON THEIR RIGHTS TO
GOOU AND MUGGED,, OR MURDE
THEY ARE OPPRESSED ENOUGH  IT
IS.
AND E WORLD OF OPPSSIN MEN
E PERPETRATORS A THE VICTIMS
.
THAT'S RIGHT, RICHER SJECTS.
WH HAPPENS TO  WHEN WE LET
VIOLENTHUGOUT INTO THE
POPUTION AND ELIMINATE THIS
SENTCE F CRIME.
YOU DON'T HE TO BE THAT I HAVE
A POST OF XT TO MY BED,T'S
A SHE, LIKE A RACAR.
OF COURSE, AFTTHOSE ENHANCEMTS H
UP QUKER THAN NIKK 63 MINUT
BEFOREHOWTIME.
SO TY SHOW APPRECIATION BY
GETTING A W TTOO.
NOW HE HAS T TELL THEM, IT'S UP
B.
BUT YOU'VE GO TO HAND IT TO HI
, HE'SOT SOME SERIO
STREETCRIT, I DON'TNOW IF
ERE'S ANYTHING LOV THAT
MIGHT TO GET H NAME TTOO
MY FACE.
LET ME THINK.
I WONDER WHAT T WOD HAVE.
ARE THOSE DETAILS OFTH NEW SENT.
ACCORDING TO FOXWS, HE WILLE
LE TO QUALIFY FOR YOH
OFFEND PARE WHICHLIMITS HISHIS
YOU THINHE'L SEE THAT OUT, YOU .
HE WILFINISH THE SENTENC
ARND T TIME I FINISH THIS
LET'S WEOME TONIGHT'SUEST
HE IS ON OUR LIST OF  UNDER 40
WHO LOOK KE THEY ARE 14
FOX WS CONTRIBUTOR GUY BENS.
SHE PUTS THE FUN IN DISCUSSG
BRIDONEY MARKET FUS.FOX NEWS COE
.HE CALLEIT PSON BECAUSE T
AUDICE TES CYANIDE.
AND FINALLY, S NDS HAVE MORE
FUN IF I FIND YOUMEANRREST
WARRANTS, FOX NEWSCONTRITOR KATP
>> I WANTED POINT OU THAT
LF OUR STUDIDIEN IS
STUCK IN AN EVATOR, THAT'SOW
SMALOUR AUDIENCE IS.
NOT DDING.
GENE IS STK IN AN ELEVOR,
BU HE'S BEEN ERE FOR A LONG
TIMEYOU KNOWHAT?
I D'T CARE.
TICKET I DID NOT KNOWAT.>> STUC.
BEEN THERE FOR LO TIME
CK TO THSHOW.
CK TO THE SHOW
WH IS THE POINT OF BEING A
WOKE D
DOES LETTING CRIMINALS CK ONTO
THE STET HP THEM?
WHAT IS THE POTPREAD.
>> I WANT TO KE A GET THE
ROYALTY CHECKF TH.
>> ARE YOUARRY
CA IS.
GREG KNOWSHEANSWERTO HISWN QUES.
COURSE COMING AIT FROM A
VERYEGATIVE PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
VERY FOX NEWS IF YOU.
THIS IS AN INSPIRATIAL STORY
EVERY DUMPHOULDN'T.
IT'S ABEAUTIFUL FRIENDIP THAT
IS BSSOMING HERE AN YOU JUST
WANT TO FOCUS ON THEMURDER.
SOMETIMES MURDERERGET TATTOOS
REPRENTING THEIR VTIMS
GUY THAT IS HPING THEM OUT
GREAT I THINK ERE OULD MAYBE
BE ASITCOM OR SOTHINGIN THIS
.
>> THIS LIKE PROGRESSWE'VE GO
IMPRESVE THAT HE KNOWSABOUT
HIM.
>> HE'S LIKE LONG ON THE
DETAILED.
>> WLD ALSOONNA DO IMPRIN.
HE'S GOING TBE OUT SOON, SO
YOU BETTERAY SOMETHING NE
ABOUT M.
HE' CUTE.
JE IS A BI Y HE CAN HANDLE
HIMSF.
LET'S LK ABT THE IMPACT OF
ASE TATTOOS ANJOB INTERVIEWS
.IT'S GOT TO DUCE YOUR CHANS
FOR AOB.>>YES, IF YOU NTO THINK
ABOUT IT TH WAY.
AT MAKES A LOT OF SEN.KN, IN TE
HAVE  PNT OUT THAT A THE
HIGH CME RE HERE IN NEWYORK
.
MYAMILY WAS RY CONCERNED
ABOUT  WITTHE BROOKLYN
SHOOTING
AS AN ASIAN WOMAN I GET ND OF
SCAREDETTING ON TH NEW YORK
SUBW.
>>I WOULD TOO, AND'M N ASIAN WO.
WHO OWS WHAT I'LLBE U TO
THIS WEEKEND
INICE LITTLE COMBINATI.
WHERE IS YO PIP
I DON'T KNO AT I'M SAYG.
>> WOW.
>> WHER DOETHIS GO?
WEKNOW THAT WE SEE TH AND
IT LIKE IT'S STL HAPPENING.
WHERE ARE E ADULTS?
>> ION'T KNOW.GASCON S DONE AN
HERE.HE'S GOT BOTH THE CPS AND
BLOODS.>> HIS T UNIFIER.
>> IF THEY CA DO IT SOCAN THE
REPUBLICANS AN THDEMOCRATS.
IT AMANG TO ME THAT ESE
PEOPLE VE SUCH HATRED FORE
PEOPLE THEY REPRESEN THAT THEY
ARE WATCHI THE CRIME GO UP AND
HE EVEN GOT A FAN BOWHO'S
GEING A TATTOO WITH SNAME,
THAT'S ABSD.
HE SHOULD GET QR CODE TATTOO
SOHAN YOU JUST TE PICTE
INTOOES DIRECTLY TTHE LICE
REPORT.
>> LOVE QR CODES.
AREN'T THEY N FAS.
>>HEY' NOT CONCERNEDITH HATE WHN
WI PREOUS FOOD ON I, IT
DRIVES  CRAZY,HE HAVE TH BIG
GIT CHEESECAKE CTORY MENU,
THEY HAVE SO MANY TIONS AND
THEN ALL TH TH STUFF START
SLIDING DO IN LAP, DOT
NEEDTHAT.
I LIKEHE QCODE, THE IS NO
FOOD STUCK TO E QRCODE.
HAVE YOU NICEDHAT?
>> AVENUE NEVETHOUTABOUT
THAT.
>> THAT'WHY I ASKED T
QUESTIS AND YOU ARE ANSWING
THEM.
>> ARE YOU ING ASK ONE>> IAD OT
I'M A LITTLEWORRIED ABOU JEAN
APPED IN AN ELEVAT.
'SKIND OF THW ME OFF A
LITT BIT.
THUGH ME ON MYAME.
I CANALMOST AR HI FAINT
SCRES.
THERE'NOT A LOT OFAIR INHE
ELEVATOR A HE'A BIG BOY
LET'S TKABOUT TATTOOS.
YOU DATED GUYS WITHTAOOS.
>>OF COURSE.
THAT'S BECAUSET'S T.>> TRE LL B
THAT ATTRTIVE.>> ESN'HAVE TO BE
TO KEEP PREFEBLY ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
>>ET'S ICK TO THE TOPIC.
YOU GONE OFFOPICIRD U OK AS THE
IP READ.
>> NO YET, SOMEDAY Y BE
THINK IN GENERAL LOTS OF
MANDATORY MIMUMS CAN AD TO A
T OF INJUSTICI DON'T LIKE THE WY
KIND OF REMOVE THABILITY TO
CONSIDER THGS ON A
CASEY-CASE BAS.
DON' THINKHE PY SHE
SHLD BETARTING IS GETTG
MURDERS OUT EARLY.
I THI THERE'S LOT OF THINGS
YOU CAN IMOVE IN THEYSTEM.
I'NOT LOSING SLEEP OV I
GHT LOSE SLEEP TH MORE
MURDERERS SPRE>> SO U'RE TALKIN.
USE TO LK PEOPLE UP O REPEATEDS
W WE LET THEMUT A THEY
ORISSA DEVICE.
>> HDIDN'T DO THINGS, HE DID A
MURD.
TH'S WHEN I REAL DOT LIKE.
AND TH TY JUST KEEP DOG IT
OVER A OVER AGAIN.
ISN'T HE GOING TOE RELLED
RSKY THERE IS A RELL
ELECTION AGAINST HIS OPPONENTN
N FRCISCO A FEW WKS FROM
NOW.
AOT OF PEOPLEARE WATCHING
THAT ON CLELY.
I THINK THE POINT AT KAT HAS
IS AN IMPORTANT ON.
I INK WE CAN TALK ABOUT
CRIMAL JUSTIC REFORM OR
NONVIONT FENDERS, AND THIS
IS H THE SELL IT TO U BUT
THIS IS A RDERER AND A GANG
MEMBERWHO ED A GUN, THESAY
THEYE ALL AGAINST NS A
EN THERE FIGURING T WAYS.
>> HIM OUT OPRISON, THAT IS THE
POLICY IN ISOING TO SWING E
PENDUL BACK HARD-CORE TO A
ALW ORR MESSAGE.
IT A BAIT AND SWITCH D
RDER
ALL THE PEOP TH ARE BEING
LEFT OUT, INCLING AT ARE BEING
CALIRNIA ALONE.
IN NUMBER JUSTADE UP.
DIDN'T CO EITHER THAT OR A
DRUM TOO.
BERE WE GO, ANOTR RENDER
THAT IS SO EXCITG.
LESS THANTWO WEEKS AY OM
WELCING BACK OUR UDIO
AUENCE.
STARTING MAY 2 WE HAVE A NEW
STUDIO GRETO GET YOUR EETICKETS.
UPEXT, DOES DISNEY NEED PLA